we've been chatting with kristen bell
and dax shepard and just talking about
everything with them is so much fun they
are the greatest and they've been so
open and honest with us but we thought
hmm
we want to see how far we could take it
so we whipped up some extra spicy
questions for them to see how much they
would reveal about one another and as
usual they did not disappoint take a
look
zach when was the last time you lied to
kristen to get out of a plan
it would probably be
that like i had to go away to shoot top
gear and i claim that the the only
flight was at three and there wasn't a
seven and i want to make sure i had a
backup plan in case i missed the flight
maybe there was a third flight that
that's probably likely because she likes
to
she'll fly and get in and and then have
five minutes to go to work and then
she'll fly right out after set i i have
a different temperament i need to like
get there and do all my little things
and get comfy and if i could add
something you wanted an earlier flight
because you had downloaded a new netflix
show and you wanted to sit in bed with
no
buddy
needing you for anything and not talking
to anyone so you got there maybe even a
day early and the cute thing is it
wasn't even alive because i know him so
well i know when he's doing that i know
his co-workers i know when they're
getting there and i'm like oh you're
flying on tuesday that's a weird deck
you're playing tuesday night dad's
playing sunday oh oh okay that's fine
it's hard for me because i know what she
would do she would she would spend the
maximum amount of time with the family
and go at the last minute but i i won't
i want to i want to get away i i want a
day
to hang before i then work but honey i
know you're weaker than i am so i let
you get away with all of that yeah i
appreciate it dax does kristen believe
in any conspiracy theories bigfoot
bermuda triangle something crazy
no i don't think you're a huge
conspiracy theory person it's not a
conspiracy theory but i'm definitely
such a sucker for any sort of like new
supplement
i'm just like this so this is it
this is what's going to fix everything
this is going to change your gut biome
is going to be uh do a 180 after we need
62 subs this is it it's all these
different things when i really needed to
get a handle on it was right after we
had the kids and i was going to stop
breastfeeding and i had read
i can't even look at you when i say this
i read that camel milk was really
similar to um breast milk and then i i
bought a bag of dehydrated camel milk
online and it got there and i opened it
up and i was like
what are you doing yeah online camel
milk
probably make its way into our
children's
dehydrated online camel milk
it was powdered and i thought you know
what
put this up at the top of the shelf as a
reminder to how far you could go and
when you need to rein it in and go like
hello remember earth
speaking of
babies and breastfeeding i was reading
the story
about there's a term for it too cystitis
mastitis
may i ask a personal question is that
like
the hottest
just know that when you answer
we will for the next three months be a
news cycle uh which is fine with me you
know we did it it happened with the
bathing suit it happened with uh
showers
showers
because i realized the level of
commitment
that this man had to me
let's just say i extracted mestitus
and we'll leave everyone's imagination
to wander
i just know i also added is not easy
and it's not rewarding i mean it is to
know that you've helped your partner but
other than that
it's it's it's uh it's where the rubber
meets the road it's down in the trenches
you know
uh
kristen does dax google himself
no he does not because he does not ever
like to see any pictures of himself
under any circumstance yeah if i never
see a photo of myself before i die
that'll be a big he hates the way he
looks so i think he's got his clearly
his visions going
but he
he doesn't and it's why he sometimes
gets grumpy during hair makeup and
wardrobe photo shoots photo shoots for
sure and i apologize every photographer
that's ever worked but i go in ahead of
time and i go fyi if my husband's a
little grumpy it has nothing to do with
you it's that he knows his picture's
gonna be taken and he doesn't like that
because he feels insecure
and they're always like oh that's so
sweet and then
yeah he does not google himself
jax when was the last time christian got
jealous
my wife's incredibly confident as she
should be there was a ton of jealousy
at the beginning of the relationship for
pretty you know good reasons i had never
i had been in an open relationship for
nine years um
i was blacked out a big chunk of my life
uh you know there were a lot of things
for her to be concerned about but
i'd say once we um got
engaged some
kind of switch for me seemed to change
and i find her to be
incredibly not jealous which is a very
hot characteristic in a partner
i said
if i may i said i bet i can answer this
for kristen
um that she's too confident and she
doesn't get jealous and you have every
reason
to be confident um
you are
working on every cylinder and spinning
every plate and just the complete
package
and it's what makes me want to be in
this relationship
and i have such mad respect for you guys
and i thank you for having this
conversation with me to bring the good
word about the first american
run diaper factory that you guys are
bringing to our country and i'm
in awe once again at hello bella's
newest and latest greatest
thank you
we will
i love you guys so much please have the
best rest of your day congratulations on
this and i will speak to you soon
thank you
thank you kristen and zach
for bringing us this important story
hello bello diapers are available on
hellobillow.com
and major retail stores all over the
place
[Music]